what i love about seeing bats is just
how graceful they are
the way they fly they flip they flutter
they move
they're just stunning
it was just kind of a love at first
sight that has stayed with me my entire
life
they're just part of my world
i am kirsten alvi mudd
the executive director and founder of
missouri bat census
and i'm a bat lady
when we heard word in 2006 about white
nose syndrome
i knew that we had a very short window
white nose syndrome is a fungus it grows
on a bat's nose on its wings on its tail
anywhere where the bat doesn't have fur
it causes it to wake too many times from
its winter hibernation sleep
they may hang where they're at in a cave
and just starve to death
or fly out on a cold day and will be
lost on the landscape
see these little blotches in his wing
that's what we're looking for
it also invades a bat's wings tissue
and it eats away at their wings
okay but it's almost spring buddy you
got a chance to make it some of your
roomies did not survive
see how we have a dead bed here another
bat right there
another good sized one there
it's really hard not just because i
enjoy the caving but i enjoy the bats
themselves and i just want to do
everything to protect them and help them
hang on until we find some method that
we can intervene on their behalf
we've began our bat rescue and rehab
programs here in the state of missouri
are you hungry
right now the bats that i have at my
location are all big brown bats these
guys all came into us as little orphaned
hairless pups in the next few weeks
they'll be getting a chance to see if
they can fly and eat and maintain their
weight on their own in the hopes of
releasing them back into the wild are
you looking for more
there are so many misconceptions about
bats
i just wish that everybody would realize
that
they have an integral part of our
ecosystem
there's a real sense of pride that we
have helped these bats gain in
population numbers
nobody has to pat me on the back for it
i feel it it's the thank you from them
as i see many more and more of them
surviving and living healthy and happy
that's what i'm out for
you